hi guys hi everyone I'm just doing an
interim so wage just crashed a little
bit but we're back playing Claire and
that's the game we're playing
look this house is ours thank you for
tuning in everyone yeah so we're back
and we're playing Claire which is made
by how strong games yeah one statement
cetera set respired by silent hill 2d
side-scroller similar to boys way this
girl cool Claire we just found out dog
creepy things are happening in the
hospital now I don't understand how this
map works because it is a 2d
side-scroller
Wow I can kind of understand what it's
going happy son calls so many bears I
should start from the beginning I don't
know how I got here I don't know where I
am
I don't know where to go okay that's
very informative oh here we go bathrooms
bang my body tense just now maybe this
is what working out feels like silently
didn't see that coming
dang it rohad you cannot like them does
it go through dog oh let's assume yes I
was mistaken
oh oh MLG George does just like Mario
nice back okay now we're like what hey
Annie
no ten year old in history of the
wireless ever said I'm gonna call you
Anubis what is that sound
I needs the monsters again we can hide
in that cabinet Oh My Jesus that monster
there all right time to go time to go oh
yes it is
just give me a game let's get out of
here
oh it's begging on the door okay down is
left know what I'm smoking yes
pediatrician scary pediatrician oh
that's for the crash hey oh what a kid I
was surprised
Claire I found some candy oh my gosh
here you go oh I need to take it have a
few minutes clay you Grunk London he's a
looking FASTA the door pots are crushed
those are the important parts it's up
because up is sometimes right and down
is sometimes left and sometimes it's
inconsistent with what it wants to be
found a battery I kind of Maxo battery
Maxim Marcel for when you're in a
haunted hospital and you can't find your
way around rely on max oh one two I
found warm coffee hmm
nada max cell battery to you wait a
minute what aware yes
no you're right oh I am there's a room
on the Left I just oh you know what
never mind
I guess that's a game maybe stand on the
face the dog oh boy
didn't even have to hold a breath of
that long god damn you Maxell I'll never
buy another back cell battery someone's
just like happily we [ __ ] outside
with that some of the same it's really
scary right
storage room here that's right it's not
inscribed on that stupid back ripe up
then needs a going direction of that
grave doubt box
bingo squiggly line this is creepy it's
dangerous to walk around with a lit
light up Oh scary lady hello dear hello
what's your name sweetheart
Lorene Claire nice to meet you Claire
I'm Eleanor but you can call me al have
you seen luck it anywhere I look it yes
that's a picture of my children and my
grandchildren this is embarrassing but I
can't remember their faces
I don't fret dear I'll find it I'd like
to help you look
Oh where my man owes money mrs. but you
can come he'll okay yeah but that was
the slowest pursuit ever that was so
funny she's like I hope he doesn't catch
me Oh God no people asking me why I
sounded like a parrot a pretty shot of
an old lady sounds like alright yeah
class skip leg day for sure oh yes I
didn't see what she did
Thank You Claire you're welcome
I'd almost given up hope I'm in
searching for this locket for a long
time now I'm American oh never mind may
I see your family sure they are
beautifly won again
you did it now I'm doing it it's
contagious so but of course I would say
that hey hey hold on to that okay I
won't lips mom a race game good good
here yeah don't give up hope okay I you
never know who will come to help you
nobody comes to help you I mean you came
to save me dr. Mueller Mueller
come on lockpick damn it max L will he
bring his disappointment and long life
batteries actually it must not be very
long laughs you know I'm gonna give me a
picked up yes he's the co Oh he came he
came he came he's in the thing he's in
the thing he's in the room yes yes I am
running the fleshless not doing oh it is
a monster that's scary
Oh left sorry okay I'm ready to second
he comes that slow-speed pursuit that
was clear
yes that was clear available on Steam
mode Asura developed by hailstorm games
if you're interested in the game you can
check it out there for yourself
we'll be back next week we will just be
in the horse okay brand-new exciting
things that happen uh if you wanna grab
this game steamed Asura
I'm you wanna do and let us know what
you want to see as always mmm-hmm yay
they all next week
bye everyone